like many of you out there I'm a huge
fan of Batman got a bad I'm compelled to
consume anything and everything to do
with the Dark Knight it's my burden my
curse
I play the games I read the comics I
watched the animated series even by the
novelty towel that doubles up as a cape
fact wearing it right now
so with season 3 of Gotham upon us I
decided it was time to get caught up so
I'll watch five episodes a day over the
last 10 days and came to realize three
things first
it will never be Gotham central second
if you can get over that it's actually
quite good and third buck cheek cramps
are very very painful like many of you I
was skeptical to start with the first
half of season 1 is messy directionless
and full of painfully awkward pandering
but I stuck with it and much to my
surprise I'm glad that I did as a TV
show Gotham isn't exactly up there with
Breaking Bad the wire or even Batman the
Animated Series but not everything has
to be for fans of the Bat verse there's
a lot to be enjoyed in the series if you
haven't given it a shot or maybe dropped
out early there's a few reasons why
Gotham is worth your time but viewer
beware
there's going to be some spoilers ahead
sir look at me don't look at me
my name is Jim Jim Gordon
the vast majority of stories involving
Jim Gordon are set in his dog days when
he's already been appointed commissioner
the most notable exception is Batman
year one in which he's a rookie cop but
most of his life is depicted within
these two time frames you see Jim Gordon
is Batman staunchest Ally but we've seen
so little of his time in Gotham which is
where the TV series comes in here he's a
newcomer to the GCPD he's punched surfer
teens in the OC served the law in the
Southland
and now he's ready to dispense some
pills of justice on the streets of
Gotham get your girls ready mr. Pell's
Gordon is a paragon of law and order and
his first case is the murder of Thomas
and Martha Wayne this investigation
underpins the first two seasons of the
show but in between his hunt for the
Wayne's killer
Gordon deals with gang warfare
corruption in the GCPD conspiracies in
the government and of course his fair
share of weird villains the city of
Gotham is Jim Gordon's crucible and we
get to watch it slowly erode his morals
and challenge his resolve the Jim Gordon
we're almost familiar with is weathered
tired and at times looks like he's
barely hanging on
it's clay he's been through trials and
tribulations and Gotham gives us a
chance to see all that happened four
years Batman fans have been told how
Gotham is a Corrupter and how it can
turn good people bad this is something
that the series explores really well
with Jim as the unfortunate victim he
stubbornly faithful to the letter of the
law but as the series progresses he's
backed into corners and forced to make
compromises episode by episode we see
Gotham chip away at him and by the end
of season two we're starting to see it
take its toll it's not the most nuanced
exploration of the character it's
definitely a new perspective
we need each other we're family
while Gordon tries to clean up the
streets the criminal underworld stands
on the brink of all-out war at the top
of the food chain is carmine Falcone who
faces competition from the rival Maroni
family but there's also dissent within
his own ranks from fish Mooney he feels
it's time for Falcone to step aside
because he's old and he doesn't
understand the kids and because she has
powerful hair and everyone needs to
respect the hair sorry if you let this
hair go frizzy you will be that's not
important because on the chess board
that is Gotham's criminal underworld
it's the story of Oswald Cobblepot a
pawn that rises to be king that proves
to be most compelling young Cobblepot
begins as a lowly human umbrella Stan
but gets to sneak in sniveling and
backstabbing his way up the ladder he
hobbles around a mob world playing
double agent triple agent police
informant and any other role that will
get him ahead the great thing about
watching Cobblepot rise to the top is
the way that everyone underestimates him
at the slightest hint of danger he's on
his knees groveling pledging new
allegiances and betraying allies but
behind it there's a wickedness and
cunningness he's truly a terrible person
but you also kind of want to see him
succeed he spends the first season
rapping Gotham's most rich and powerful
around his finger before outright
igniting a war you know a standard day
for the penguin there's not a lot of
memorable penguin stories out there so
Gotham stands out as one of the stronger
interpretations of the character
before long Gotham gives up on trying to
be a gritty crime drama and embraces the
Batman law that's when it starts to come
into its own it dares to introduce big
villains and it does a pretty decent job
with it for some ups to play it safe
like with Richard sionis who is a wolf
of wallstreet type exec that's making
his employees fight to the death they
don't make a big deal about him but
eagle-eyed fans will know that he goes
on to become the sadistic black mask for
others like Jerome Valeska it's a little
more daring and with good results
who is Jerome Valeska uh hey you ask
well nobody really just a son of a
murdered carnival performer right up
until you see their air-to-air rictus
grin and hear that hair-raising laugh is
he the Joker the show never quite says
and that's the beauty of it
one of my personal favorite things about
Gotham is what the show does with Edward
nygma aka the Riddler the TV series cast
him as a forensic expert for the GCPD
constantly being stepped on by his
colleagues causes a split personality to
emerge on the one side we have the
socially awkward guy trying to fit in on
the other we have the mad genius persona
tempting him to give in to his darker
urges the transformation is spread
across two seasons but it's thrilling to
watch and all the time we see him
transform into one of Batman's most
troublesome adversaries why are you
doing this because it's fun
in season two of Gotham the right has
become a little less reluctant to draw
from the vast amounts of Batman lore out
there the short Victor freeze arc which
is really annoying because the show
keeps calling him Victor fries there's a
lot of similarities to heart of ice from
Batman the Animated Series
it shows Victor fighting to save his
wife Nora stepping into villainy as time
runs out and cops closing on him like
harvest it has a tragic conclusion
that's befitting of the character if you
haven't seen a heart of ice by the way
stop what you're doing and watch it
because it is the best mr. free story
ever told
then there's your introduction of theo
galavan a highly intelligent politically
minded figure that quickly wins the
hearts of Gotham citizens to become a
shoo-in for replacing Mayor James who by
the way has come a long way since being
the hypochondriac from scrubs things get
a little more interesting when it's
revealed theo galavan's real surname is
du ma he's one of the last surviving
members of a long-forgotten family that
tells tells of a super heroic crusader
called Azrael shall I tell you a secret
then there's a matter of Indian Hill a
plot of land near Arkham Asylum that is
rumored to house dark secrets it
purports to heal the sick but there's
clearly weird things going on I mean
there has to be after all it's headed up
by someone very strange the series
starts plucking from sources from across
the years and stacking all of it on top
of each other that might sound like
overkill but Gotham does it in a way
that creates something that feels
uniquely its own and that's why you
should watch it so there you have it a
few reasons why I think Gotham is
actually a good Batman show I really
didn't expect to enjoy it or even look
forward to season 3 but here I am
telling you it's worth checking out so
you planning to catch up with Gotham
what do you completely disagree with
what I said let me know in the comments
below or come and find me on Twitter
where I'm at to more Hegg now if you
excuse me I've got some office crime to
fight
you